yippy Kaymer be lovers I'm John and
today i'm revealing 14 hidden easter
eggs adorable callbacks to the first
movie and cameos you missed into all the
boys PS i still love you plus I'll be
explaining the secret end credits teaser
that sets up the third and final movie
in the trilogy spoilers ahead if you
haven't seen the film yet let's do this
remember how Laura Jean fell on her back
in a faint when Peter spoke to her about
the love letter she wrote to him in the
first movie well it seems like LJ has
something of a habit of falling down
during meet coots that she lands flat on
her back again when she runs into John
Ambrose for the first time in the sequel
though this time it's a bowl of candy
that sends her crashing to the ground in
those two moments we see al J literally
falling for Peter and John and it seems
pretty fitting that Laura jeans
meet-cute with John mirrors her
meet-cute with Peter given that they all
end up in a love triangle together when
Lara Jean wins a snow globe at the
funfair with Peter she asks him to watch
as she tips it upside down and then back
again showering the couple inside the
globe with snow what LJ doesn't realize
is that this foreshadows how her world
will be turned upside down by John
Ambrose later in the movie like the snow
globe couple she ends up kissing John in
the snow it's a funny thing this
relationship stuff one moment things are
upside-down but then like magic there's
glitter everywhere and once it all
settles you're right back in the fairy
tale again as LJ unwittingly predicted
when her kiss with John Ambrose doesn't
feel right Peter arrived to bring the
glitter back and they both end up with
another sort of fairy tale ending when
Laura Jean and friends get together in
their old treehouse haunt
there are numerous memories from their
childhood pinned on the walls behind
them one of particular note is a drawing
that's reminiscent of a Harry Potter
sorting hat a link back to how LJ and
John Ambrose used to read Harry Potter
together in the treehouse you said your
house Hufflepuff and that was my house
too and I thought maybe that was a sign
that we were meant to be there's also a
couple of pictures of a dog in the
treehouse which could be Chris's rescue
pup she mentioned earlier in the movie
or it could be a nod to the novels where
kitty had a rescue dog named Jamie Foxx
Pikul there was already a hat tip to
that family dog from the book in the
first movie when kitty asked her father
can we
dog now no but that's a nice dry if
you're a fan of the two older boys book
trilogy you were likely delighted to see
author Jenny Han pop up in the first
movie as a chaperone Lucas and Lara Jean
school dance this time she makes an
appearance during the Valentine's Day
scene in the school cafeteria just
before the a cappella group appears on
screen serenading a fellow student you
can spot Jenny comforting a crying
likely lovelorn teenage girl as a
producer on the to all the boys movies
Han has also been a major influence on
Lara jeans on-screen style
collaborating closely with the
franchise's costume department but Jenny
isn't the only member of the hard family
to show up on screen and PS I still love
you in the Korean New Year scene you can
see her real-life parents playing Laura
jeans grandparents in fact Han told the
LA Times that she and her mother even
taught Alana Condor and a cathcart who
plays kissy and jong-kul Beth who plays
their dad how to properly greet their
relatives for the scene PS I still love
you continues in the first films
tradition of referencing 80s
coming-of-age movies by kicking off with
Lara Jean energetically dancing too then
he kissed me by the crystals in a
tribute to the 1987 feature adventures
in babysitting
in fact LJ actually recreates many of
the key moments from the opening scene
of that film such as miming the song in
front of her mirror spinning across the
room singing I love you too a portrait
of her boyfriend before kissing it using
her curtains to make a bride's veil and
then finally falling back on the bed and
tipping her head to face the camera
kissy of course jolts Lara Jean back to
life with a sharp reminder that
seriously Lara Jean now at the time to
be fantasizing about living in an 80s
movie and that moment itself as a funny
callback to how the 80s was such an
important cultural reference for LJ in
the first film for example when they
formulated their fake relationship rules
Lara Jean used the opening scene of the
1984 movie Sixteen Candles as a basis
for the rule that Peter was allowed to
put his hand in her back pocket and she
insisted he watched the film with her it
seems perfectly fitting there's a
franchise based on a set of much-loved
novels to do its bit to celebrate the
joy of reading in the school corridor
when LJ and Peter were discussing John
Ambrose's letter look carefully at the
background and there are a couple of
displays with the words books can take
you anywhere and reading gives you wings
together with a beautiful 3d display of
butterflies bursting out of a pair of
books when Lara Jean uses an Ice Cream
Sandwich to demonstrate to Lucas just
how much she overthinks her relationship
with Peter it's an amusing moment
has Peter a share of an ice cream
sandwich with someone before maybe it's
me
maybe I'm the one who wants to do more
than just share an ice cream sandwich
but the choice of this particular snack
is a deliberate Easter Egg - Jenny Hans
novel in the book when the group gets
together at the treehouse
LJ packs a bag full of ice cream
sandwiches and cheese doodles rather
than the cupcake she bakes and the pizza
John Ambrose brings in the movie and
just like in the book where Peter takes
the last ice-cream sandwich in the movie
he also NAB's the last slice of pizza
she stole like he was in middle school
what does that mean at parties and stuff
he would always take the last slice of
pizza and then whenever you tried to
call him out on it he'd be like I'm an
athlete when Laura Jean reads her
original lassiter John Ambrose memories
of the Halloween party she dressed up
for come flooding back
I felt so lame like I didn't fit in and
then you walked in as a deviled egg and
I realized maybe I'm lame in a cool way
of course of blueberry that the young LJ
was is part of her french toast costume
but it's also a lovely shout-out to the
novel in which Lara Jean has what she
describes as a charming and jaunty beret
collection when heater first finds out
he's in a potential love triangle with
LJ and John Ambrose the moment perfectly
reflects their situation not only are he
an Al J in a biology class at the time
but the teacher is talking about how
octopuses have three hearts and like in
their love triangle one of those octopus
hearts is about to get broken by Laura
Jean who died sex it and friends of a
squeamish Peter foreshadowing their
breakup later in the film but that's not
the only bit of foreshadowing in this
classroom scene because there's also a
hint at the location where Peter and
LJ's relationship will come to an end
the octopus is a mollusc and we will get
to see one of those during next week's
visit the Portland
oh and if you think back to the first
film it was also in front of a fish tank
at a party that Jen and her friends
nosily quizzed LJ about her new
relationship with Peter what do you want
to know everything when oh how far it's
on being its up and down on pain and it
was in that same spot that Laura gene
and Peter took selfies to make Jen
jealous of their fake relationship the
first movie had a mid-credits scene that
teased the return of John Ambrose in the
sequel and to all the boys too also has
a little and credits tease for the third
movie though it's very well-hidden the
song that plays right at the end of the
credits is called better by myself it's
by the band hey violet who said it's
about realizing that sometimes it's
better to be on your own and learn how
to love yourself before you try to love
anyone else or be with someone that
doesn't put in the effort you need them
to
if you've read Jenny Hans novels then
you'll know that always and forever
Laura Jean which is a final book in the
trilogy focuses on the complications
that arise when LJ and Peter look to
life after high school and their plans
for college the end credits song in this
movie doesn't necessarily mean LJ and
Peter will break up for good but it does
hint that LJ may spend some time by
herself working out what's best for her
in the long run I am trying to make sure
you know how to rev your own engine make
sure you know how to look after you and
get it again it the cast and crew have
already filmed all the boys three
straight after PS I love you and Lana
Condor said it's definitely the
franchise's most mature movie and in an
interview with Entertainment Tonight she
revealed that in the third film LJ
really starts to make decisions for
herself that might be unpopular but at
the end of the day as a young woman you
have to protect your own heart and make
the decisions that are truly right for
you regardless of the other people
around you on a separate note as to
whether John Ambrose will ever make a
reappearance in Laurens life actor
Jordan Fisher is keeping his lips sealed
however Fisher and a Cathcart Lana
Condor and even Noah Santonio have all
said that they think that Peter is great
for LJ's younger years while John is an
endgame boyfriend or husband there's
certainly plenty of debate among fans
over whether Peter or John is the better
partner for Laura Jean and I did a full
breakdown in discussion about whether LJ
made the right decision in my ending
explained video tap the screen here or
follow the link in the video description
to watch that now did you spot any other
Easter eggs in the sequel and what do
you want to see happen in the final film
let me know in the comments below
if you enjoyed this be sure to subscribe
for all my new videos including
Netflix's Sabrina you lock and key and
stranger things tapleft my next video or
tap write for another video you're sure
to like thanks for watching and see you
next time yippee-ki-yay movie lovers